[Música]
olaf scholz de brindes é mais um vídeo e
hoje vão ensinar como fazer uma mexida
guerra de papel que declara 36 elásticos
esse projeto que foi mais pedido no
último vídeo então e que está o
resultado do vosso pedido é para fazerem
estão precisar de folhas com o tamanho
a3 mas vocês não tiverem podem sempre
juntar folhas com tamanha quatro que são
aquelas que só alguns anos impressoras
lá em casa
vão ser também do condutor com caixa de
medição ou seja que o motor tem alguma
força e gira muito legais mas se vocês
não tiverem não quiserem comprar online
podem sempre de ensinar uma manivela
letra 1 no cic onde fica o motor e sim
vão conseguir parar de modo manual mas
claro fica sempre mais bacana se você
estiver em um motor e de parar em modo
automático em senhora fim o tutorial
[Música]
só
ficou bom
[Música]
o ofk o
hebron só estamos a chegar ao fim o
esperto não gostar deste projeto aqui e
agora vou aproveitar esta parte por
perguntar por que vocês querem para a
próxima semana
esta semana eu vou tentar publicar o
vídeo do avião foi por caneta 3d que boa
semana e eu ainda não sei então gosto
sempre de saber o que vocês preferem em
primeiro lugar temos uma espada dobre
com o tempo foi que vocês tem que
imprimir nas folhas claríssima populam
possui cortam colam e fuja só pintar no
final pra ficar como você desejar em
seguida temos uma pistola que foi feita
do modo bastante simples e minimalista e
quando de simples é mesmo simples que
lhes para 5 elástico que vocês conseguem
fazer isso em menos de 20 minutos e
depois por fim tínhamos um tanque que
anda e depois dispara também a cabeça
não é rotativa só luanda e dispara já
anda pra frente e atrás roda e tal
depois dispara porque se for para mudar
a cabeça do tanque então é mais
complicado você vai precisar potencial
outras coisas então eu fui fazer este
projecto bastante simples só com carros
e motores coisas que vocês vão ter em
casa e isso então deixe nos comentários
que vocês gostariam de ver na próxima
semana e caso você tenha uma ou outra
ideia podem deixar também que depois
posso perguntar vocês no outro vídeo
para 31 receber a placa de um milhão de
inscritos do canal inglês e já agradeça
muito vocês frente que veio no canal em
inglês também e em breve quem sabe
também teremos uma placa aqui no canal
muito obrigado steve sol
tchau